Wohin Leute, guck mal was Microsoft heute so zeigt.
Es dauert noch eine halbe Stunde bis es losgeht.
Wir müssen jetzt gerade mal gucken, wo wir am besten gucken.
Wo gucken wir denn am besten?
Okay, wir gucken Twitch, da können wir das nämlich wieder in VLC gucken.
Oder, Moment, Moment, wir gucken ja Microsoft, das heißt wir müssen jetzt auf Mixer gucken,
oder?
Gucken wir mal auf Mixer, für die originale Microsoft Experience, oh, nur für Erwachsene.
Na, Chat, das wird aber nix, dann müssen wir auf Twitch gucken.
Nee, wir gucken das, wir gucken das garantiert nicht auf Mixer.
Soll ich geh' jetzt noch mal kurz aufs Klo, und dann geht's los?
So, gucken wir mal hier, Twitch, Xbox, das nehme ich gut, da kann man das wieder in
VLC schauen.
Ich hab' übrigens mein, ich hab' mein Memeboard geupgraded, das kann jetzt noch mehr.
Ups, äh, Desktop, Streamlink, Streamlink, und jetzt Streamlink, Moment, ich muss den
jetzt mal in VLC aufmachen.
Streamlink, Excel, den setz ich heute mal in der Wende aus, mal gucken, ob's funktioniert.
Ähm, funktioniert, sehr schön, easy, easy, klar, dann kann man das zumachen.
So, ich zeig' euch mal was, also, ich kann's euch nicht zeigen, ich hab' jetzt, ich hab'
mein Memetool, hab' ich netzwerkfähig gemacht, ich hab' jetzt auf dem zweiten Rechner, also
quasi auch auf dem zweiten Monitor, aber das könnt ihr auch auf dem Notebook machen
oder theoretisch auch auf einem Tablet, wenn ich mal gucke, wie man das am besten macht.
Ne, das Update ist nicht aufgetabt, das stimmt, so, und, das heißt, ich kann jetzt auf dem
zweiten Monitor, kann ich jetzt klicken und ich hab' ne Vorschau an Bildern, kann ich
jetzt zum Beispiel hier anklicken, auf dem zweiten Monitor, das heißt, ich muss mir
nicht mehr 50 Shortcuts merken, so, erst mal auf Twitter posten, dass es losgeht.
Donation, dankeschön, ich muss erst noch mal bei mir auf dem zweiten Bildschirm aufmachen,
da ich hoff' was seh', Tippy Stream, 437, danke für alles, ja, danke für die Donation.
Guck mal, der E-AX ist auch am Start, so, ähm, dann machen wir hier mal aus und machen
den VLC an, gucken schon mal, dass die Lautstärke stimmt, oh, die Musik, oh, hast du schon den
Battlefield 5 Gameplay geguckt von Jack Fraggs, nein, sieht besser aus als der schimmelige
Trailer, ja, der, was ist das für Musik, ich hab' auch das Gefühl, der Sound ist lauter
bei Microsoft als gestern bei EA, ich mach' mal kurz einen Ticken leiser, bis, bis es
losgeht, da mach' ich volle Pulle, ist wieder Bullshit-Bingo am Start, nee, mir ist irgendwie
nix gescheites eingefallen für Microsoft, außer, dass Phil Spencer wahrscheinlich
wieder ein geiles T-Shirt anhatte, Typ hat ja immer die besten T-Shirts an, bin begeistert,
wie viele Leute, 22 Uhr dabei sind heute, French in 2K18, bin ich zu spät, nein, bist
du nicht, es geht noch nicht los, es geht ab 22 Uhr los, aber nachdem ihr anscheinend
eine ordentliche Zeitzone hier drauf zu schreiben, zu schwierig ist, stimmt natürlich keiner
Zeit, die hier drauf steht, also es ist 22 Uhr, ja, D-E-G-M-G-M-G-S-M-T, wie heißt
unsere Zeitzone, Sommerzeit, ach, keine Ahnung, GMT plus 2, Hauptsache 2x NA, ja, das
kriegen die nicht auf die Reihe, West Coast und East, das ist zu kompliziert.
Also, ich zeig euch was, ich hab' das jetzt abgecradet, ich kann jetzt auf, also gestern
hatte ich ja das Problem, da ich hier zum Einplanten musste ich mir ja gestern schon
irgendwie 18 verschiedene Shortcuts oder so merken, und jetzt habe ich hier auf meinem
zweiten Monitor an Bord, wo ich draufklicken kann, ist ganz praktisch, also ich denke wir
sind jetzt optimal ausgerüstet für jegliche Emotionen, die heute im Livestream auftreten
könnten, ja, also ganz wichtig, wir haben, wenn ein paar Grills am Start sind, haben
wir hier, hatten wir gestern nicht, wenn wir klatschen müssen, haben wir auch was zum
klatschen, und was haben wir noch Neues, Runde Cringe, hatten wir gestern auch nicht, Jebaited
Copper Pride, Weep Weep, Herzchen, ja, ich hab' abgecradet heute, und ganz wichtig, das
hätten wir gestern bei EL schon gebraucht, aber das ist bei Microsoft bestimmt auch anwendbar,
haben wir noch was Neues, gucken, ich glaube das war's, ahja, und natürlich, so, also
bis es losgeht, weil wir haben jetzt noch 20 Minuten Zeit, müssen wir uns jetzt mal
die neuesten PC Master Race Memes angucken, wenn wir schon dabei sind, das ist geil, das
hab ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen, einfach so, ey ohne Scheiß Leute, so war das wirklich,
oder, 2007 beim ersten Crysis haben alle Leute gesagt, boah ey, wie geil Spiele bestimmt
in den nächsten 10 Jahren aussehen, und was kommt, Fortnite, oder du guckst dir mit uns
Battlefield 5 Gameplay an, können wir auch machen, wollen wir Battlefield 5 Gameplay
gucken, ich hab' mich eine Playlist-Freund hier, jemand eine Playlist geschickt, mit
allen, hat der Meshed eins, da gucken wir jetzt, falls der Meshed eins hat, gucken wir
den Meshed an, oder ein bisschen Werbung machen, hat der Meshed ein Battlefield 5 Gameplay,
nein, hat er nicht, warum nicht, Finn, was ist da los, irgendjemand hat auch noch vorhin
eine Battlefield 5 Gameplay-Liste geschickt, genau hier, ahja, weil grad einer schreibt,
was von Realm Royale, ich hab' heute gespielt, Realm Royale, ich hab' gleich in der dritten
Runde, oder so, hab' ich bei Engineer ausgepackt, und gleich ist der Insta-GG, Easy Noob, weggefecht,
ok, Battlefield 5, was ist denn jetzt bei Microsoft angekündigt, keine Ahnung, müssen wir uns
überraschen lassen, naja, sie werden wahrscheinlich irgendeine Marke ausbuddeln, aus ihrem, aus
ihrem ollen Zeug und komplett verhunzen, oder irgendwie sowas wie Scalebound wieder vorstellen,
was dann eingestellt wird, so, was gucken wir uns denn für den Battlefield 5 Gameplay
an, Grand Operations, mich interessiert vielmehr Rush, New Battlefield 5 Early Access Gameplay
from E3, mit Krill, Krill, komm, wir gucken jetzt mal, wie das Krill spielt, und, aber
ich, die Musik von der Microsoft-PK, das ist ja grausam, was ist das denn, was da läuft,
das hört sich an wegen so Pornmusik, oder, hört euch das mal an, Gachi Bass, was ist
das, Gachi Bass fehlt mir noch als Emote,
kannst du Gaben rotieren lassen, weil du's bist, ja, kann ich machen, da muss aber, Achtung,
da wird's einem, das Epilepsie Warnung, ja, du kriegst da echt Kopfschmerzen davon, Max,
kannst du die ganze Geschichte hinter den Gachi Memes, ist das nicht aus irgendeinem
Porno, oder war das was anderes, keine Ahnung, ich hab irgendwo mal was gelesen, kann es
sein, dass ich das durcheinander bringe, Max ist Donation angekommen, ich hab Donation
übersehen, ja klar, danke für alles, hab ich auch vorher gelesen, danke für die Donation,
Alpha, Alpha X, nice, übrigens, wenn ich jetzt es tatsächlich mal schaffen sollte,
noch dreimal zu streamen, ne, viermal, dreimal, dreimal zu streamen, in den nächsten, in
den nächsten paar Tagen, ich mein, der Monat ist noch lang, dann darf ich auch wieder Affiliate
beantragen, ich mein, durfte ich ja schon, hab ich ja nicht gemacht, dann darf ich's
jetzt wieder, mal gucken, ob ich's diesmal mache, ok, gucken wir uns das Video von Jack
Faxx an, aber ohne Gelaber, sondern mit dieser geilen Microsoft Musik im Hintergrund, also
was sehen wir denn hier, wir sehen Leute, die aus einem Flugzeug springen, oder besser
gesagt, wahrscheinlich aus einem Heli springen, und das ist ein bisschen geruckelt, sehen wir,
und Motionplur, Motionplur ist das Schlimmste, was, das kommt aus der Community von Forsen,
ja das wundert mich nicht, Moment, Moment, Moment, ich hab jetzt, hab ich nicht hingeguckt,
ist das M-Com, ist das M-Com direkt unterm Flugzeug, oder was, Moment, wenn das M-Com
direkt unterm Flugzeug wäre, wäre ich irgendwie bescheuert, ach ne, ne, da hat es bloß geschnitten,
es ist auch noch 15 Minuten, dann geht's los, A Demon Rider schreibt, Battlefield 5 sieht
für ihn nach einem Battlefield 1 DLC aus, finde ich gar nicht, ich hab ja Battlefield
1 nicht gespielt, also nur die Alpha, Beta, und da hab ich gedacht, das hab ich kein Bock
auf das Game, aber ich finde, es macht einen viel besseren Eindruck als Battlefield 1 auf
mich jetzt schon, und das was ich im ersten Trailer gesehen hab, ich hoffe es wird nicht
so, irgendwie so random, wie Battlefield 1, da bin ich, auf das neue Revive-System bin
ich ja mal gespannt, ich mein, es kann jetzt am Endeffekt jeder das eigene Squad reviven,
und halt der Medic kann alle reviven halt schneller, ich bin mal gespannt, ich mein, das Reviven
war seit, ich mein, in Battlefield 4 ging es noch, in Battlefield 4 konnte es wenigstens
noch ordentlich Rätstrain machen, nicht immer ganz so krass wie in Battlefield 3, aber ich
finde, das ist gerade das, was Battlefield 3 und Bad Company 2 für mich geil gemacht
haben, dass du halt so richtig schön Dauer-Rätsten konntest, Dauer wiederbeleben, da haben die
Fights einfach länger gedauert, und du musstest dir nicht in die Hose machen, dass du verrechst,
wenn du wusstest, das hat sich halt richtig gelohnt, wenn du ein gutes Team als Backup
hattest, da wusstest du, hey, selbst wenn ich jetzt verkacke, es rettet mich einer, immer,
ich weiss nicht, halt in Bad Company 2 quasi so viele zu null wurden, obwohl die überhaupt
nicht zu null waren, einfach nur weil ich ein gutes Team hatte, ja gut, so wirklich
viele sieht man jetzt auch nicht davon, außer, dass Panzer endlich wieder wie Panzer aussehen,
und ich, die Microsoft Musik, die macht alles irgendwie ziemlich, weißte, ungehyped, oder?
Weggeschneibt, den hätte ich auch getroffen, den Schuss, mit Ton, ja, ich will jetzt nicht
quasi mehr Check-Frags im Stream anhören, das gibt es ja noch, Anzeige ist raus, Strike
ist raus, aber wenn er es interessiert, der kann sich das Video selbst angucken, ich meine,
ich muss jetzt ja nicht restreamen und ihm quasi viewer-glauben, auch wenn die 180 jetzt
wahrscheinlich es auch nicht fett machen bei ihm, sag mal, hat nicht jemand was geschrieben,
es geht angeblich schon irgendwie um halb was los, so Pre-Show oder sowas, aber ich
finde es gut, dass man die Waffen, dass man so die klassischen World War 2 Waffen hier
wieder am Start hat, also MP40, STG, 44, okay, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendein russischer
Schneiper oder so, keine Ahnung, das ist die komische, diese, wie auch immer Japaner
Gun, oder wie das, ich weiß nicht wie das Teil heißt, das gibt es aber auch, gab es
aber auch in fast allen World War 2 Spielen, das Teil, das hat schon in allen Games ein
absolut grottisches Iron-Side gehabt, dass man es eigentlich nicht spielen will, schlimmste
Variante war in CoD 5, da hast du kaum was gesehen durch das Iron-Side von dem Teil,
bam, okay, da sieht man, dass es nicht so viel ist, es ist halt Kills zusammengeschnitten,
okay, das neue Revive-Animation, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, dieses realistische Machen
von Revives, da weiß ich nicht, ob ich das geil finde, das von Battlefield 4 war ein ganz
guter Kompromiss, du konntest schön weit retten, halt zwar nicht voll, wenn du schnell, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das so gut finde, wenn die Revives halt ewig dauern, wo dann wieder
weniger Leute Medic spielen dadurch und alles irgendwie viel mehr Camp-lastig wird, weil
sich keiner mehr traut, so, gleich geht es, ich wollte übrigens auch aufs Battlefield
ein, aber das muss ich jetzt durchhalten, so, was haben wir noch, was haben wir sonst
auf Battlefield nicht zu bieten, hat er Lost vielleicht, eins hochgeladen weiß ich, gucken,
wer ist ja auch da, also ich glaube, dass das Video hier von Lanai, keine Ahnung, Lanai,
dürfte glaube ich auch ausführlich sein, ich meine, das ist einfach eine komplette
Runde, 31 Minuten, ok, hier sieht man jetzt aber ein bisschen mehr, das ist einfach Gameplay,
das finde ich nicht schlecht, da kann man sich das beste Bild von machen, also einen
Rekt-Meme brauche ich noch, das muss ich mal aufschreiben und irgendeinen Gatchi-Buzz
oder sowas, ich bin mal gespannt, was Phil Spencer heute für ein T-Shirt anhat, ach,
hat er das geschrieben Frozen, warum Embargo und die anderen dürfen, das ist auch wieder
so zwei Klassen-Zeugs da, hallo, der GFB, das ist mit der Microsoft-Pornomusik im Hintergrund,
das klingt so dumm an, vor allem hat's Microsoft nötig da irgendwie, was ist das, gamerfreie
Musik oder was? Was ist deine Meinung dazu, dass GitHub von Microsoft gekauft wurde? Erst
mal abwarten, das war meine Meinung zu, Microsoft hat viele Projekte auf GitHub, sind glaube
ich sogar, wenn man rein von Commits und SourceCode und so ab sieht, der größte Open-Source-Contributor
mittlerweile der Welt, bei Microsoft, muss man sich mal vorstellen, ja, das ist die Bill
Gates-Einschlafmusik, das hört sich echt so an, das hört sich wirklich, ja, ich meine,
optisch, ja, aber das hat Battlefield 1 schon auch gemacht, optisch macht das Game wirklich
Spaß her. Oh, die Musik ist vorbei, oder? Naja, es geht schon wieder los. Hat das Vorteil,
dass du den Stream in VLC guckst, ja, ich kann den Vollscreen machen, ohne dass irgendwelche
Controls und so eingeplendet werden, wenn ich was drücke. Es kommt keine Werbung. Wie
sieht es eigentlich dein Vorschau-Memeboard aus? Ja, ich würde es euch gerne zeigen,
aber ich habe so einen zweiten Rechner, kann ich nicht, das ist aber ganz billig, das ist
einfach ein Fenster mit 26 Buttons, wo halt ein Mini-Thumbnail von dem jeweiligen Bild
drauf ist. Ja, das finde ich auch, die Polarlichter sehen wirklich gut aus, weil ich glaube, dass
solche Sachen, die machen so immer viel her, aber ich glaube, die sind nicht so schwierig.
Ich habe die Musik extra leise, weil das noch Pornomusik ist bei Microsoft im Stream. Ich
mache sobald es losgeht, mache ich an. Achso, soll ich übrigens den Chat eingeplendet
lassen, oder soll ich den Chat raus machen? Wie fandet ihr das gestern? Ich habe mir das
im Nachhinein noch mal angeguckt, ich fand das gar nicht so übel mit Chat. Was ist das
Zombie-Modus? Kommt heute wieder ein Blitzeinschlag, ich hoffe nicht. Okay, Chat anlassen, gut,
lass den Chat an. Der ist ja nur ganz klein unten rechts in der Ecke. Das sieht ein bisschen
aus wie Waldparaiso an der Stelle, ne? Guck mal, das sieht wirklich aus wie Waldparaiso
an der Stelle, wartet mal, guck mal, guck mal. Hier hast du die Hauptstraße, du musst ein
Stückchen zurück. Hier geht es hinter zum nächsten M, komm, hier ist, das sieht wirklich
ein bisschen aus. Und hier rechts hast du den Berg, wo es nicht weiter geht, hier kommt
die Hauptstraße. Es hat ein bisschen was von Waldparaiso-Rush, zweite Base, bisschen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich sieht die Map letztendlich komplett anders aus. So, machen wir mal ein
bisschen lauter, dass wir es nicht verpassen, wenn es anfängt. Ich mache da 100% Lautstärke
sobald es losgeht. Ah, nee, sie erzählt etwas. Ich dachte, wir können in-game-Sound mal hören.
Aber Sound mache ich mir bei Battlefield keine Gedanken, der Sound ist eigentlich immer super.
Die leiste Musik, ja, richtig geile Musik. Da geht mir voll einer ab, bei. Wissen deine
Arbeitskollegen eigentlich von deiner YouTube-Karriere, wenn ja, wie stehen die dazu? Also, die wenigsten
wissen das. Ein paar wissen es. Und außer, dass man ab und zu ein bisschen was darüber
erzählt, ist das eigentlich nicht so oft, dass wir darüber, das interessiert, denke
ich, mal die wenigsten. Spiel mal in BDO. Oh, ich muss noch Daily-Rewards abholen. So,
jetzt müsste es gleich losgehen. Das, guckt mal, das sieht wirklich aus wie Valparaiso.
Wenn ihr da reinlauft, guckt mal. Guck mal. Hier, hier ist das M-Com drin, normalerweise.
Hier ist die Hauptstraße, hier geht es weiter zum nächsten Punkt. Rechts ist ein Berg. Gibt
es auch ein Cringe-Meme für die nächste Microsoft-Minecraft-Show. Aber alles am Start heute. Alles am Start,
nicht beschweren hier. Arbeitest du eigentlich wieder fünf Tage die Woche? Ne. Das werde
ich auch nicht machen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das durchgehalten habe überhaupt
so lange. Am liebsten würde ich ja noch weniger arbeiten die Woche. Wieder nur 1008 SP verfügbar.
Ja, das ist halt wahrscheinlich, wenn ich jetzt Affiliate wäre, dann hätte ich dann
wieder alle Optionen. Ich bin noch nicht würdig genug, dass ich, wenn viel auf Twitch los
ist, Coding-Optionen, Kodak-Optionen und Gedönskrieg. Warum weniger als fünf Tage, dass ich mehr
Zeit für YouTube und Stream und Zeugs habe? Das war mal der ursprüngliche Gedanke, als
ich das gemacht habe. Mein YouTube-Video-Output hält sich an Grenzen. Aus dem Gesichtspunkt
wüsste ich das eigentlich nicht machen. Aber ich sage euch, Leute, es ist sehr angenehm,
immer drei Tage Wochenende zu haben. Ich habe jetzt immer Samstag, Sonntag, Montag frei.
Der Gedanke dahinter war eigentlich, wir müssen mal umschalten, geht gleich los. Oh, da stand
auf Deutsch da gerade. Habt ihr es gesehen? Sie haben es geschafft. Okay, gleich geht's
los. Hype intensifies. Oder auch nicht. Ich habe nämlich überhaupt keine Ahnung, was
uns da erwartet heute von Microsoft. Wahrscheinlich Halo 6 oder so. Nee, warte mal. Halo 8? Ich
weiß nicht mal, bei welchem Halo wir eigentlich sind. Halo 25? Sea of Thieves 2? Das wär's
jetzt, ey. So, es ist 22 Uhr, Leute. Warum geht's nicht los? Warum geht's nicht los?
Ah, jetzt geht's los. So, ich mache mal volle Pulle Lautstärke. So, falls es zu laut, zu
leise ist, sonst was. Sagt's einfach. So, Phil Spencer T-Shirt. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
was er anhat. Game Engine Demonstration.
Ist das ReCore oder wie das hieß? Das gab's noch schon und das ist gefloppt. Nee, das
ist was anderes. Monster Hunter X-Box Edition. Was ist das?
Halo? Halo! Ich wusste es.
Halo Battle Royale. Infinite. Ich hab kein Wort mehr zu nominieren.
Da ist er. Was hat er für ein T-Shirt an? Zeig her.
Das ist ja heute ganz normal.
Creativity Unleashed. Die haben es drauf hier. Mixer. Moin Mixer.
Lautstärke, okay. Bitte zehn Prozent nach.
100 Prozent der Prozesse von euren Fanfest-Tickets gehen zu Gamers Outreach. Danke an euch, Kinder
und Kinderhospitaler, die mit ihren Freunden in ihren Lieblings-Welten spielen. Das ist
eine tolle Sache. Das ist das, was ich am meisten an Gaming mag. Gaming bringt uns zusammen.
Gaming verbindet uns. Es inspiriert unsere truesten Kooperationen. Es kreiert einige
unserer fondesten Erinnerungen an der Wettbewerbung und unsere tiefsten Gespräche über die
Geschichten innerhalb von Games. Am meisten fosters Gaming eine echte Gemeinschaft. Es
erhält sich über Alter, Fähigkeit, Race, Gender und Geografie. Das ist das, wieso ich immer
glaube. Und ich werde immer glauben, dass Gaming das große Unifier ist. Und das, was uns
unifiziert, ist unser gespartes Liebe für diese Artform. Legendäre Charaktere, die uns
nicht nur für zehn Stunden kreieren, sondern für zehn, zwanzig, dreißig Jahre. Bedeutende
Geschichten, die uns den Helden inspirieren. Iconische Wörter, die uns so richlich vorstellen,
dass wir Freude im Luft und Gefahr auf den Seen fühlen. Als Spieler sind wir in einem momentanen
Zeitpunkt, wo kreative Vision und künftige Technologie zusammen die Artform, die wir lieben,
so. Für Monate sind unsere Teams und ich die Welt reisen, um Entwickler aus Japan und Polen
zu treffen. Von den UK zu den Ukraine, von großen Studios zu einzelnen Entwicklern. Kreativen,
die die volle Macht und Potenzial von Xbox One sehen, um ihre derartigsten Vision für
Games. Today we curated a bold showcase of their best work. And ours. Fifty Games. Eighteen
titles with exclusivity and eighteen world premieres. Some will be first timers on any
stage. All are imagined by the industry's greatest talents. All demonstrate what true
artisans can create. Mind blowing art, immersive sound effects, breathtaking worlds. So let's
jump in. Exclusive. Ist das Ori 2?
ich hab, ich hab jetzt einfach geraten.
Ist doch was anderes.
Ja, das muss Ori sein. Ja.
Das ist doch schon mal was Gescheites. Uncharted 5. Nein. Wow. Irgendwas Japanisches. Garantiert
was japanisches.
Stelz-Game.
Kokona. Ein Stelz Action RPG im alten Japan. Interpretier Stelz mal so rein.
Wow.
Deine Todeszeit kommt nicht so leicht.
Was Neues! Das ist nicht schlecht! Wo ist denn das?
Das war kein großer Applaus!
Ich weiß, dass Phil wirklich wundervoll ist, aber er hat viele Freunde!
Und das Gute ist, dass ihr auch unsere Freunde seid.
Wir hatten eine unglaubliche 16 Jahre Geschichte mit Xbox, die bis zum Original mit Morrowind ging.
Jetzt ist es nach hinten kompatibel.
Und das geht alles in die Richtung von Mods zu Konsolen mit Fallout 4.
Und jetzt bringen wir das Fallout-Universum mit Fallout 4 mit dem Xbox Game Pass heute aus.
Und hey, seit wir hier sind, dachten wir, dass wir euch einen exklusiven, ersten Blick auf Fallout 76 geben.
Ja, Fallout 76 ist ein Präquel an alle anderen Spiele.
Und es ist unser größter noch.
Es ist viermal die Größe von Fallout 4.
Der Größe allein macht es nicht aus.
Ich glaube, dass das dann irgendwie einer Fallout-69-Porn hochlädt. Würde mich nicht wundern.
300 Jahre nachdem unsere große Nation begonnen hat,
sind wir zusammen, um die Fertigung von Fallout 76 zu erinnern.
Dieses flachende Untergrundschelter wurde von Vault-Tech verarbeitet,
aber es wurde von euch gebaut.
So, dass, wenn die Bomben kommen, unser Leben dauern wird.
Nichts als fucking Trees.
Nicht nur Wälder, nicht nur Gebäude, aber Herz und Geist.
Und letztendlich Amerika selbst.
In Fallout 76 beginnt unser Zukunft.
I can hear you, but I'm afraid to be near for you.
I don't know where to begin.
It's just me, Captain Spirit.
Das ist Chris zu der fliegenden Fortress.
Habt ihr den Schneemannsern gesucht?
Noch nicht.
Haltet mich postiert.
Chris, Frühstück!
Okay, Vater!
Du trinkst Bier?
Ich brauche keine Elektro für meinen Sohn.
Ich werde immer als Letztes für den Team in der Schule gewählt.
Und sie werfen die Bälle nie auf mich.
Sie können nicht Geschichten wie du erzählen, oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Start!
Start the launch!
Too late!
Emergency!
Am.
This time, you won't get away from me.
I'm a small smile.
Me too.
You're probably going to change the world.
I hope so.
I know so.
Captain Spirit is here!
The Awesome Adventure.
The Awesome Adventures of Captain Spirit.
Download for free from June 26th.
Exclusive.
Okay.
Fällt mir nichts zu ein. Großartig.
Mal gucken, was es ist am Ende.
Commander Jax, on deck.
Welcome to Crackdown 3.
The only game built like me.
Big, beautiful, like a skyscraper.
Falling at your face.
If you want to play on my level, follow my lead.
Somebody give me my jam.
It's all about getting the jump on the enemy.
No building is too high.
Sixty stories up, incoming.
You gotta build up that raw power.
Grab more, grow more.
Big, bigger, Jax down.
Then you need that firepower.
Homing rocket gun, bullseye.
Four check cannon,
four check cannon.
And the most involved weapon on the map.
And then I roll out like a boss.
I can put your fools.
Pull up the side of the building.
I bust out my very own tech.
Oh yeah.
Man, these bad guys just won't quit.
They got mad.
Mad scientists.
And mad at master plans.
We will take back our world from the scourge of the machines.
Okay.
I think are going.
Auch mit ihrem echten Stil, der vor uns steht,
mit dem Stink von Maschinenöl und seiner heretischen Lichtung auf uns.
Erinnern Sie sich, die meisten der Länder wurden zerstört oder beschäftigt.
Auch diejenigen, die unsere Sprache sprechen, können Gegner sein,
aus Verwaltung oder aus Angst.
Wir werden nicht verbrechen.
Lassen wir uns gegen sie stehlen.
Denn dies ist unsere Stunde der Glorie.
Amen!
Lass uns los, Artyom.
Ja, das ist Metro. Klar ist es Metro.
Spätestens bei dem Namen weiß man es jetzt.
Davon kann es ruhig noch ein Teil geben. Die waren alle ganz gut.
Sie wollen Blut? Sie werden es bekommen. Wir werden es übernehmen, egal was die Fanatiken denken.
Und wenn die Heretik für unsere Leben kommen, werden wir feststehen.
Und so hast du mich, du verdammte Heretik.
Das kann kommen. Nächstes Jahr oder dreiviertel Jahr hin.
Davon haben alle gute Games.
Da kann es ruhig noch ein neues geben.
Okay, hätte ich jetzt genauso gut auch nichts sagen können.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ist das jetzt ein neues?
Das muss ein neues sein.
Das rockelt, das rockelt, das rockelt die ganze Zeit.
Das ist nicht das du lebst, das ist Game.
Ralf.
Kontrollieren? Nein, alles, was ich tue, ist, Leute zu verletzen.
Das ist mein Zuhause jetzt, ich kann nicht zurückkommen.
Ich will niemanden verletzen.
Verletzen!
Hör auf!
Roxis gibt es. Sein Herz ist in meinem Herz.
Die andere Twilight Town ist nur Data.
Also was wird Elsa akzeptieren? Licht oder Dunkelheit?
Ich weiß, ich will wissen.
Gut für dich, aber was? Ich werde sie nicht in die Dunkelheit lassen.
Da ist Keyblade.
Wer ist das? Mickey, du bist zu spät.
Oh nein!
Ich tue jetzt gerade so, als wäre das der Wahnsinns-Erfolg gewesen.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, der Artstyle von Sea of Thieves hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Die Wälder von Veränderungen rollen durch die Seen, und ein neues Land wird gezeigt.
Die verletzten Seen.
Ein Ort der Dunkelheit, wo Feuer und Asche alle konsumieren.
Und von der Depthe werden Skeleton-Krüge aufgewachsen, um die Seen zu verletzen.
Eine antike Wälderin hat sich auf den See der Dunkel entgegengelegt.
Du hast mir die Bedeutung des Schicksals verliehen lassen.
Du wolltest nur wissen, wie viel es wert war, oder?
Okay, ich gebe dir 10 für es.
Oh nein, das ist Battlefield.
Finish in 2K17? 18? 19?
Äh, ja. Und weiter?
Popke? Nein, zum Glück nicht Popke, sondern halt Forza.
Minecraft kommt bestimmt auch noch.
Interessiert mich nicht.
Sollte ja wirklich was taugen für Leute, die auf Rennspiele stehen.
Ist überhaupt nicht meins.
Die hätten euch ein bisschen mehr zu Battlefield zeigen können.
Autos. Die fahren. Hat es noch nie gegeben.
World First Premiere. Fahrende Autos.
Nicht mein Fall. Ich will es jetzt auch nicht schlechtreden oder so,
weil die Serie muss wirklich gut sein für Leute, die halt auf sowas stehen.
Das Einzige, was EA gestern nicht geschafft hat, ist random Auto fährt über die Bühne.
Vielleicht schafft das Microsoft ja heute.
Ich freue mich so sehr, es ist fantastisch, hier zu sein.
Heute bin ich gespannt, euch den World Premiere von Forza Horizon 4 zu zeigen.
Set in beautiful, historic Britain.
Forza Horizon 4 hat dynamische Szenen in einem geschehenen Open World.
Und Szenen verändern alles.
Hi Bill.
Ja, Forza. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Es ist ein geschehener Open World, wenn du mit der ganzen Community spielst.
Das bedeutet, dass die anderen Fahrer, die du im Spiel kennst,
mit all der Spontanität, Spannung und Spaß, die reale Leute bringen.
Der Typ im Hintergrund.
Ist das neu?
Einsgemeinte Frage, mit was liefen die anderen?
Das ist so action packed.
Wie in echt? Da freu ich mich auch immer mit Sportwagen auf der Straße.
Hallo aus dem Auto raus.
Die Szenen, die Zeit des Tages und die Wetterkonditionen sind dynamisch.
Aber sie sind synchronisiert für jeden Spieler,
also wird die ganze Community sie gleichzeitig erleben.
Sobald wir uns alle lieben, kann man nichts dagegen sagen.
Mal sehen, wie diese Szene im Winter aussieht.
Aber die vergangenen Teile haben mich nicht interessiert,
und das interessiert mich auch nicht.
Aber das ist halt Safe Cash Crap für Microsoft, das Ding.
Der Effekt passt richtig gut dazu.
Nicht nur Microsoft komplett erfallen lassen, ich kann das auch.
Das Schaf wurde gerade übrigens gereckt.
Das muss heutzutage.
Ich warte noch auf den Slow-Motion-Car-Door-Preach oder sowas.
Okay, das hat mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Wie die alle ausrasten, wenn er auf die Bühne kommt, ey.
Was geht ab?
Das Gleiche hat er eben selber gesagt.
Das sagt jedes Mal das Gleiche.
Das hat er eben auch schon mal gesagt.
Genau das Gleiche.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Der hat jetzt dreimal auf der Bühne das Gleiche gesagt.
Was ist das denn für ein Gelaber?
Oh, das gab es ja noch nie.
Haben wir wirklich doch mehr Zombie Survival gebraucht?
Von denen habe ich ein Game gespielt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die noch mehr Games haben.
Das fand ich aber storytechnisch echt gut.
Also die Story von Hellblade hat mir wirklich gefallen.
Gameplay war für den Arsch.
Hat das nicht total gefloppt?
Ach nee.
Okay, es ist noch nicht gefloppt, aber ich habe mir da mal gespannt.
Ich habe es mir schon voll abgehakt im Kopf.
Ich dachte, es ist schon längst raus und keiner spielt es mehr.
Wir hatten noch keine Frau auf der Bühne.
Das geht aber nicht im Jahr 2018.
Das ist auch so ein Game, das mir der Arsch überhaupt nicht zusagt.
Das haben wir aber auch schon gefühlt 50 Mal gesehen, sowas in der Richtung von dem Game.
Okay.
Das haben sie auch schon vor Ewigkeiten angekündigt.
Pupke.
Warum ist das Exclusive?
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären, warum das Exclusive ist?
Warum sagen die davor Exclusive?
Auf der Konsole Exclusive.
Pupke.
Das ist halt Pupke.
So, Aim, No Prame, Shotgun Main.
Also quasi so wie in dem Trailer ist das Spiel halt nicht.
Ich glaube, das Gameplay im Trailer hatte man nichts mit dem echten Gameplay zu tun.
Table?
Nein.
Tales of Vesperia?
Irgendeinen Tales of.
Irgendeinen Tales of ist das.
Vesperia.
Wer auf JRPGs steht, sollte das spielen.
Das war echt nicht übel.
Und es ist die Version mit allem dabei, wie es aussieht.
Weil dieses Piraten Grill war in der ursprünglichen Xbox-Version nicht dabei.
Warum weiß ich das eigentlich?
Beziehungsweise immer noch.
Wie Weed Me, Spam, Mothbucker, If Ban.
Könnte man eigentlich mal wieder spielen?
Wie gesagt, ich fand's nicht schlecht.
Das ist ja von 2013 oder so.
Division?
Was ist Division?
Oder?
Der Mann sieht so aus.
Oh nein.
Wird das Zombie-Survival?
Doch Division.
Ja doch, der Division.
Echt doch.
Hab ich am ersten Bild schon gesagt.
Da haben sie mich übelst gebaitet zwischendurch.
Ich dachte beim ersten Bild so, Division.
Oder doch nicht, oder doch nicht.
Im Endeffekt doch Division.
Far Cry 25.
Nein, Division Gameplay.
Die da im Hintergrund labern.
Soll das Ingame-Gelaber sein oder soll das so Fake TeamSpeak Discord gelaber sein?
Ich glaube, das soll Discord gelaber sein während der Mission.
Ist klar.
So rede ich auch immer online, wenn ich irgendeine Mission spiele.
Das soll TeamSpeak sein oder Discord?
So redet man auch immer, wenn man online spielt.
Das ist ja schon so Halb-Roll-Playing.
Und zumindest heißen sie Megan, Kit und Duke.
Also NixxHD, Quickscope, iSnipe, HD.
Megan, Kit, Duke.
Eigentlich fehlt ja jetzt noch irgendwie zwei Russen im Team oder so, die sich weigern,
Englisch zu sprechen.
Also, wer auch nicht Englisch sprechen kann, um die quasi echte Experience zu zeigen.
Das erinnert mich ziemlich an das erste Gameplay vom ersten Division, was sie gezeigt haben.
Gut, es war auch in der Stadt, aber das war genauso aufgebaut.
Und am Ende sah es dann zumindest nicht so aus.
Ja, das ist der Ingame-Chat.
Max FTVI, es soll der Ingame-Chat sein, ist klar.
Voll wie in echt.
Das ist quasi der Trailer von Division 1, bloß dass es jetzt um Flugzeug geht.
Was?
Der Ace hat es da nicht rausgekommen aus dem Stein, aber wenn man draufschießt ist es gut oder was?
Juggernaut.
Warum muss der Kot mit sowas anfangen?
Und jetzt wollte ich mal sagen, das Team hat mal mega NA-Aim.
Das ist ein NA-Aim, kommt zu überbieten.
Und Absinth-Movement-Gruppel.
Hab ich schon mal vor der Show an Tour gespielt oder so?
Ist klar.
Genau so läuft es in echt auch immer im Team-Speak-Up.
Ashley Spiker, jawoll.
Endlich haben wir mal einen Grill auf der Bühne.
Das Problem ist, dass Game Pass sagt.
Gut, das Spiel startet jetzt halt schneller, wenn ich Glück habe, dass die AI denkt, dass ich das spielen will.
Ja, okay. Nice. Da hat sie recht.
Das ist zum Teufel After Party.
Das ist zum Nintendo Switch Box Give And Thanks.
The Elder Scrolls Online Tamriel Unlimited
And Fallout 4
Okay sie erzählen uns jetzt was, warum Game Pass nicht ganz so sinnlos ist oder was?
Und jeder der das spielen will hat es doch schon längst
Ich erzähle euch danach mal gleich was zu den Klatschern, wenn wir fertig sind
Ich hatte ja auch schon mal die Ehre Microsoft vor Klatscher zu sein
Das ist Afterparty, noch nie gehört
Golf, yeah, endlich
Digga Wutz
Ist das For Honor nur noch schlechter oder was? Was war das gerade?
For Honor mit Delicated Server
Battle Royale Spiel, okay weg
What the fuck
Schon mal besser als EA gestern
Das ist Tomb Raider
Lara sieht auch jedes Mal ein bisschen anders aus, ne?
Lara Croft
Es fehlt noch Minecraft, Minecraft kam noch gar nicht
Das lassen sie sich nicht entgehen
Shadow of the Tomb Raider
Wird bestimmt nicht schlecht, die letzten zwei Teile waren auch gut
Jetzt kommt wieder irgendwas beknacktes
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater NG 3.0
Xash
Aber das scheint ja eh nicht mal angesagt zu sein, dass man Gameplay zeigt.
Oh nein, das ist BDO.
Das ist BDO.
Oh, da geht der...
Der macht... Der Fabian macht schneue Accounts, sag ich.
Oh nein, das ist BDO.
Das ist BDO.
Oh, da geht der...
Der macht... Der Fabian macht schneue Accounts, sag ich.
Oh nein, das ist BDO.
Der Fabian macht schneue Accounts, sage ich euch.
The curiosity I gained there cost me my first life.
I awoke again in Tarif,
village of the sorcerers.
I once thought that this would be my
true home.
Ich became changed when I first arrived
At the open question.
What exactly is the true nature
of my stone st rigorous
That exactly is the true nature
Aber schön, schönes, schönes Store hat das Game.
Also lasst euch nichts erzählen, das Spiel hat keine Story, ne?
Also ich hab das schon einige Stunden gespielt, ich weiß, das hat keine Story, vergesst's einfach.
Das ist ein...
Ein MMO aus Korea.
Im Prinzip cry mit meiner den ganzen Tag, wenn einem das gefällt, ist das super.
Und alle Charaktere schreien so rumstandardmäßig.
Na gut, warum nicht?
Wir müssen auch gucken, wo sie bleiben.
Red Dead Redemption?
Oder? Nein, nein, nein.
Nein. Ich dachte, es war so Cowboy-mäßig.
Ja, es ist Devil May Cry, wenn man den Typ gesehen hat, wusste man das, geil.
Ich meine, der junge Dante ist schon ziemlich kapperfrei.
Ja, er ist ein echter Pro, der Dämonen rundherum schnappt.
Das ist, warum ich ihn so gut funktionieren kann, um Dämonen zu kacken.
Was? Kein Chit-Chat oder Monolog? Nur richtig zu dem Punkt, oder?
Ja, garantiert Devil May Cry.
Er stand, glaube ich, sogar schon da.
Ich warte noch vier Jahre für das. Vielen Dank! Die MC ist zurück!
Englisch ist schwer.
Es sind zehn Jahre seit Devil May Cry 4 wurde eröffnet und Fans haben immerhin eine echte Serie gefragt.
Also entweder er hat schlecht geschlafen oder er hat eh was genommen. Es sieht nicht gesund aus.
Okay, Marketing blablabla, wie immer.
Ja natürlich, was sonst? Es ist immer best of all time und das beste, was wir je gemacht haben.
So ist es.
Ja Patrick, du hast schon recht.
Exclusive. Jetzt kommt Minecraft rein.
Moment. Das gibt's doch schon.
Das ist ein Addon, oder?
Das ist ein Addon? Also auf jeden Fall DLC Content.
In das Game muss so unglaublich viel Arbeit geflossen sein, dass ich mir das kaum vorstellen kann, ehrlich gesagt.
Exclusive.
Da gab's das auf der Xbox.
Zelter mit Fuchs?
Das hat schon starke Zelte an, nein.
Zumindest so voll dem grünen Dick, was er anhat, voll dem Schild und der Rest nicht so wirklich.
Okay.
Mixer? Mixer!
Jetzt sagt er schon wieder das Gleiche.
Okay.
Wie lang geht denn das? Der Wahnsinn.
Das ist irgendein Naruto-Game, oder was?
Oh, das ist für die ganzen Reaps unter uns.
Das ist für die ganzen Reaps unter uns.
Okay.
Jump Force.
Okay, halt. Prügelspiel.
Prügel-Royalspiel. Wartet's ab. Die schaffen das überall einzubauen.
Heraklitus.
Homefront 4.
Stelz.
Ich hab noch keine Zombies gesehen.
Das ist schon mal gut. Keine Zombies ist gut.
Okay.
Was geht, Chris?
Gab's den ersten Teil in Deutschland?
Die haben aber heute ganz schönes Programm, muss man echt sagen.
Von 22 Uhr bis jetzt 23 Uhr, fast 30. Die sind ja immer fertig.
Die wollen's wissen.
Okay.
Ich kann nichts dazu sagen, ich hab den ersten Teil echt gespielt.
Habt ihr den ersten Teil gespielt?
Also wie ähnlich ist es zum ersten Teil?
Okay.
Also doch Zombies.
Wie ging der Comiczeug?
Warte, was?
Nonspecific Featuredeklarations
Sie sind zurück
Ich war geboren, um Waffen zu kämpfen, mit denen keine Armee gewinnen konnte
Es gab keine Angst, keine Fehler
Die Waffen haben geändert
Und niemand war bereit für sie
Die schwarzen Hände
Sie sind die mächtigsten private Armee der Welt
Aber auch sie sollten Angst haben, was sie geschaffen haben
Das ist eine Krieg, Rico
Das ist das Zweite, Rico
Ich muss jetzt mal den Spielverderber spielen
Ich fand's langweilig
Das ist doch ein Game gewesen, das konntest du 3-4 Stunden spielen und dann war's...
Das ist langweilig
Okay, wenn ich in den Chat gucke, bin ich nicht der Einzige, der so geht
Ich fand's wirklich langweilig, das war überhaupt nicht meins
Da wird ja premiert heute hier
Hey, gesport
Gesport
What the fuck
Was?
Es gibt jetzt...
Okay, das ist irgendein Merchandise-Tolk, oder?
Es gibt jetzt Gears of War Figuren
Gears Royale, genau
Gears Royale
Das war Gears Royale
Gears of War zur realistischen Grafik
Das Combat Battle Royale
Gears Royale
... mit unseren Freunden von Funko, um einen einzigen mobilen Spinn auf die Welt von Gears zu bringen.
Mobil ist nicht der einzige neue Ort, an dem wir gehen.
Ich bin gespannt, dass auch der echte Gears of War PC-Experience in einem komplett anderen Genre, Gears Tactics, eröffnet wird.
Ihr kreiert ein ganz neues Team, zwölf Jahre vor dem Gears of War 1,
als sie einen Locust-Monstermacher verbreiten, der sich für ganze Städte zerstört.
Es ist unser Teil in dem klassischen Turn-Base-Strategy-Genre, mit einer charakter-drunden Geschichte,
schnellerer, mehr aggressiver Gameplay, ein kustomisierter Squad und Equipment,
und natürlich wäre es kein Gears-Game ohne einen massiven Boss-Battle.
Wir werden gleich mehr über Tactics mit euch erzählen.
Aber nicht nur, wie ich mir ein Strategiespiel auf dem PC vorstelle.
Und die tolle Mannschaft der Koalition arbeitet hart, um euch unser wichtigstes Gears-Wars-Titel, Gears 5, zu bringen.
Als Kate, als Kate, wird ihr über den größten, schönsten Welt, den wir je kreiert haben,
mit der Krieg für die Menschheit, die auf der Bedeutung der Stadt und innerhalb von Kate selbst.
In diesem Moment des Spiels, legt Kate eine Ressourcen-Message zu einem Revolt-Village,
wer hätte das gedacht? Das passiert ja nie!
Sie sieht bloß als Soldat in dieser Einheit 50 Milliarden durchgeschnittene Leute mit der Kettensäge,
aber den einen Ding, der alles gibt, lässt.
Ich glaube, wir sollten jetzt raus.
Hey!
Verschleiß auf!
No, Faz ist richtig, wir müssen los.
Was bist du...
Er ist tot, Mann, gib ihm einen Moment.
Er bekommt einen Moment in der Rave.
Was ist mit dir los?
Del, wir müssen los!
Ich gehe nicht.
Entschuldigung?
Seit Monaten habe ich diese Träume gehabt.
Wettbewerbe...
Aber ich glaube, das waren Texte.
Was?
Irgendetwas passiert mir.
Das sind deine Großeltern?
Enough, wir werden es später umsetzen.
Fos, fang diese Leute hoch.
Ich brauche Hilfe.
Da ist ein Ort.
Ab in den Norden.
Ich denke, wir können da eure Antworten finden.
Nein, nein!
Absolut nicht!
Wir haben Orte.
Du gehst mit mir?
Verdammt, beide von euch hören!
Ich gehe mit ihr.
Schau, wenn du verpasst bist du Generalnotiz.
Okay.
Ich drücke Jack den Koordinaten.
Nein, Corporal.
Du kommst zurück nach North Fira.
Das ist ein direkter Orte.
Gut, Captain.
Verschwinde deine Orte!
Das geht nicht um dich, es geht um mich.
Ich muss das beenden.
Schau, das ist eine Necklace.
Das ist ein Locust-Symbol.
Ja, also?
Sie wäre nie meine Wahl, ich weiß das.
Weil sie für uns sterben würde.
Ich weiß das.
Sie sind meine Wahl.
Super, da gibt es nichts dagegen zu sagen.
Ein Fehler, den sie meiner Ansicht nach gemacht haben,
ist, dass sie so sehr gefühlsmäßig machen in Gears of War.
Und die Charaktere absolut keine Tiefe haben.
Gut, mal gucken, wie es wird 2019.
Die kündigen verdammt viel für 2019 an.
Ich meine, jetzt müssen wir das Zeug noch entwickeln.
Aber so ein bisschen was dieses Jahr auf der Xbox hätte auch noch was.
Alles, was er heute den ganzen Abend gesagt hat, hätte er in drei Sätzen sagen können.
Aber dieses Jahr ist ein bisschen wenig.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Wo ist ein Spannkraft?
Schon wieder.
Wir sind in Wenden und Sherrits sicher die ganze Zeit.
um eine industrieleitende Erstparty-Studios-Organisation zu bauen.
Und wie Sie vorhin gesehen haben,
machen wir eine unserer größten Einstimmungen im Jahr
in Teams, indem wir fünf neue kreative Studios einladen.
Wir haben unser Team, unsere Firma, unsere technischen Ressourcen
eröffnet, sodass wir heute und nächstes Jahr
und alle Jahre danach
Sie werden immer das Beste im Spielen erleben.
Nur auf Xbox.
Es gibt Wörter, auf denen Sie spielen wollen.
Heroes, die gemacht werden.
Und Legenden, die werden.
Zusammen.
Danke.
Danke und habt einen guten Abend.
Windows-Seriennummern.
Ah!
Ist das CD Projekt, oder?
Gerald hat sich aber ganz schön geändert.
Es ist die Stadt der Träume.
Und ich bin ein großer Träumer.
Ha!
Wussten wir es doch.
Man hat halt absolut null vom Gameplay gesehen.
Aber ich mein, ich glaub' bisher zu dem Spiel auch gar nichts gesehen.
Okay, ich glaub' jetzt ist fertig.
Das ist der Outro-Trailer.
Also Leute, es war um Welten besser als EA gestern.
Das muss man zugeben, oder?
Ich mein, es waren immerhin ein paar geile Sachen dabei, muss man sagen.
Das neue Gears of War wird bestimmt nicht schlecht.
Das neue Tomb Raider wird bestimmt nicht schlecht.
Cyberpunk, mal gucken.
Phil Spencer hat ja gefühlt quasi bei jedem seiner Ansprachen immer das Gleiche gesagt.
Wie Committed und geil und bis in alle Zeit Xbox und so.
Und Committed und Best Ever.
Der Halo gab's ja kurz.
Halo hat man halt ein bisschen was gesehen.
Ich fand's nicht übel.
Muss ich euch ehrlich sagen, allein schon, weil sie einfach gesagt haben.
Okay, auf geht's.
Games zeigen.
Bisschen Gelaber, Games zeigen.
Das war doch, das kannst du dich ja eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Man kann jetzt natürlich sagen, Microsoft hat insgesamt vielleicht ein bisschen wenig 2018.
Ich mein, es war die großen Dinge oder die Sachen, wo man sagt, da kann man gehyped drauf sein.
Die waren eigentlich alle 2019.
Aber insgesamt war das doch nicht schlecht.
So, wann kommt denn das nächste jetzt?
Ups.
Oh, jetzt geht die Porno-Musik wieder los.
Haben wir das auch irgendwie in Deutsch?
So, Termine, Pressekonferenz. Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Bethesda kommt heute um 3 Uhr irgendwann, ne?
Oh nee, bis 3 bleibe ich nicht wach.
Ich glaube, Pizzi Games hatte eine ordentliche Übersicht davon.
Alle Pressekonferenz... Computerbilder, das mache ich nicht auf.
Das mache ich nicht auf.
Also Bethesda ist, glaube ich, um 3.30 Uhr. Das ist mir ein bisschen zu spät.
Ja, komm, wir gucken mal kurz, wann die nächsten Termine sind.
Ja.
Ihr Bethesda ist aber nachts...
Das Computerbild kann sich auch nicht wirklich entscheiden, ne?
Ob der 10. Juni jetzt ein Montag ist oder ob der 10. Juni jetzt ein Sonntag ist.
Wohler mich aber nix mehr bei der Zeitung.
Ok, morgen haben wir noch Square Enix zu bieten und Ubisoft...
Ubisoft 22 Uhr, das ist so spät.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ist der Dienstag, wenn wir da früh aufstehen, um auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Vielleicht machen wir Ubisoft morgen. Und wir gucken uns, würde ich sagen, im Laufe des Tages noch Bethesda und Digital... äh, äh, Devolver.
Entschuldigung, Devolver, gucken wir uns noch an.
Können wir irgendwann morgen Mittag oder so gucken?
Hast du einen Link zu deiner Meme-Tool? Ja, guck mal, äh, mein Getup-Profil.
Ich wollte noch wegen dem Klatschen... Ach genau, ja, da gibt's nicht viel zu erzählen.
Wir waren mal Vorklatscher für Microsoft.
Also nicht, wenn ich das vorher gewusst hätte, hätte ich mir das überlegt, ja.
Aber als ich da mal da war, hab ich mir das überlegt, ja.
Aber als ich da mal da gesessen hab, ähm, wir wurden eingeladen, das war, glaub ich, auf der Gamescom 2016.
Im Prinzip ist es auch egal, welches Jahr das gewesen ist, oder 15.
Ähm, haben sie uns eingeladen von Microsoft und ich dachte mir so, ah, das ist nice.
Mal direkt vom Hersteller, besser, kannst du, super Platz, alles schon vorher.
Und, ah, super, ne, gehen wir hin.
Also ich bin mit Felix da und auf einmal kommen sie vorher schon an und erzählen uns dann so, ah, wie super und toll das wird.
Und was für alles, dass danach dann auch, gibt's irgendwo kostenlos Essen und alles.
Ja, so ein übelst gut Wetter gemacht.
Wir haben uns so gefragt, was ist mit denen los, irgendwie so.
Die sind so ultra freundlich, das stimmt doch irgendwas, ne.
Und irgendwann haben wir es dann gecheckt.
Da haben sie uns nämlich alle so ne Tasche in die Hand gedrückt mit Zeugs drin, unter anderem Xbox-T-Shirts.
Grüne Xbox-T-Shirts, da stand so was drauf, irgendwas in der Richtung wie, ähm, I witnessed the greatest games of all times.
Oder irgendwie sowas, wir haben es ja heute gesehen, Microsoft ist ja immer sehr, sehr bescheiden, ja, was das angeht.
Und da wollten sie, dass wir uns alle die Xbox-T-Shirts anziehen und da haben sie uns dann quasi schon vorher in diesen Raum, also in diesen Saal geschleust, wo die Pressekonferenz war und in die erste Reihe gehockt.
Beziehungsweise in die ersten zwei Reihen.
Und da ist es dann gedämmert, nachdem sie dann auch angefangen haben uns vorher ein bisschen anzuheizen mit Gelaber.
Und, ähm, so, ey, wir durften sogar Phil Spencer Fragen stellen, ja, haben sie uns ganz, ganz voll angekündigt, so.
Für, nur für die besten, für die tollsten Xbox-Fans und sowas.
Und bis, bis es dann irgendwann gedämmert ist, die haben uns da vorne hingesetzt und so zugeschleimt einfach, dass wir anklatschen.
Das habe ich am Anfang nicht gecheckt.
Aber es war letztendlich doch nicht schlecht.
Sowas mal aus der ersten Reihe zu sehen war ganz nice.
Alt direkt vom Hersteller ist eh immer am besten oder direkt vom Veranstalter.
Und jetzt habe ich ein schickes Xbox-T-Shirt, das ich die greatest games of all time gewitnessed habe.
Richtig sell-out, ja.
Und wir haben beim, beim Essen, danach, wo es gab es gegenüber so einen Burgerladen, hat Felix den, den echten Anklatscher, die echten Anklatscher von Microsoft entlarvt.
Da stand nämlich einer mit so einer grünen Xbox-Hose an, halt ohne Xbox-T-Shirt und so, also mit diesem Mmert.
Da stand nämlich einer mit so einer grünen Xbox-Hose an, halt ohne Xbox-T-Shirt und so, also nicht mit dem Microsoft-T-Shirt, sondern mit diesem normalen Xbox-T-Shirt und einer grünen Hose, da meinte der Felix so, boah ey, du hast dich aber hier, du wusstest ja gar nicht, was so auf dich zukommt, aber du hast jetzt passende Hose dazu angezogen, es war schon mal Glück, dass das so gepasst hat, ne?
Und dann meinte der Typ so, ne ne, ich bin von Microsoft, die haben halt so ihre eigenen Leute dann drunter gemischt, so nach dem Motto zum gehypt sein, aber ganz ehrlich, warum nicht?
Scheiß drauf, bisschen Hype muss sein, wenn da nicht gehypt wird, hypt der sonst keiner.
Wie öffnet man das Meme-Tool? Du brauchst Visual Studio und musst dir selbst kompilieren, da ist nur der Source Code auf der Tab.
Es gibt noch kein offizielles Release davon. Ja Computerbild, das machen wir jetzt mal wieder zu, sehr eklig.
Das ist auch so eklig wie Pilze auf dem PC, was ist das überhaupt, Lüfter? Ah, das ist auch so eklig wie Pilze auf dem Lüfter.
Nur eine Stelle, wo Pilze noch ekliger sind als auf dem Lüfter, aber da gehen wir jetzt nicht näher drauf ein.
Gut, ich hoffe euch hat der Streben gefallen, mal gucken was wir morgen machen, wann wir anfangen, morgen habe ich frei. Ja, Samstag, Sonntag, Montag bin ich immer am Start.
Joa, ich könnte ja morgen mal mein Real Royal, äh, wie heißt es da? Crown Royal Gameplay hochladen auf YouTube.
Wie ich als Obernoob die noch noobigere Noobs gebarst habe, geht irgendwie 22 Minuten, aber das Gameplay ist schlecht.
Ja Leute, schlaft gut, machts gut, bis morgen, tschüss.
Hast du in Overwatch League All Access Pass? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Machts gut, tschüss, CU.